hey guys it's Justine and Jenna today
we're in my kitchen but we are not
baking anything thank goodness we're
unboxing a new LG gaming monitor but
that's not it
but wait there's more a regular monitor
before oh my goodness for my regular
needs super excited to try this one out
now let's put this back on the ground so
Jenna already unbox that one so let's
unbox this one as a surprise this is the
gaming monitor I have been doing a lot
of things around this place I'm redoing
my office I completely painted this
entire place like it's super exciting
and really the new gaming monitor for
the gaming office this is my left hand
and you're using your right hand I named
the dexterous this knife is garbage what
are you using Katzen cooking right on
boss you are a monster you haven't
provided any alternative knife so these
are all the things that he's lovely
it's adorable
I am a huge Johnson it's an inside joke
you guys weren't here for it what's
happening
we need that there's pieces in there
stop on the ground and take them out as
we smell ground and then we can lift it
out
[Music]
maybe a labrets my spirits back this is
your spirit Wow oh it is curved I've
been chatting with LG I've murdered them
in the past and this is so exciting
because they were like we want to send
juice and stuff for your new office and
so this is actually a surprise because I
didn't even know what they were gonna
send so this is the 34 inch curved
painting okay this is so nice
you will then you hold that my goodness
don't move this the lego movie 2 game is
gonna look so great this looks so good
that's my dog my favorite thing about LG
monitor is how loud the dog is while the
red looks cool it does look cool
Matthew hey Matt you you you're getting
full named you're getting full name cuz
you're sad whoa what is your favorite
thing about my there's new about the LG
monitors is how simple it is together
like this screw in like it says on the
poster behind us look though tools and
then although be trying to do this by
myself on the 34 inch ultra rod and
water feels like I can do this oh I know
oh oh my goodness this looks so freakin
great oh wait maybe I want one of these
now two USB
as for your cable management hdmi we've
got two USB ports that HDMI to HDMI and
then we have something else that says do
not use no way yeah it says services
only let's plug in whoa oh my goodness I
need a moment I'm gonna get my computer
wait
with my dongle I love one of these
monitors where are you gonna put this
I'm going to put it somewhere okay this
is it's going like this oh my goodness
let me throw some content over there
whoa whoa Johnathan super high quality
it's crispy content it is super crispy
now let's see what my on crispy content
looks like wow it's weird cuz you're on
the screen and you're here I'm super
excited about this I will give you guys
a little view of it when I have it set
up in my desk but right now we have to
open
oh look at this
turn this way look at this easy easy
you gotta just get in there and hurt you
Wow okay so one of the things that I am
excited about the Jenna brought up is
that it does have Thunderbolt so this
will work really well with your MacBook
or even your mo
pro so this is just the power cord it
also has the joystick button look no way
that's good loving this this is gonna be
so great
alright there's one last thing I don't
know what this is but LG sent this and
it has my name on it so I'm not sure
I absolutely no idea was inside of here
that's that's my Netflix on my logo like
they have my actual logo okay look at
this so shiny beautiful this is cool
whoa look at this the little tiny
figures is this me this is me it's go by
little day want it this is Soak user
really cute very premium this is
extremely premium all right what is this
hotel Charles I don't know oh my gosh is
a birthday gift
happy birthday just seen LG OLED TV team
is prepared a small gift is on the
bridge birthday we made this jacket with
your name written in Korean oh way cool
oh my gosh
and my name is on the sleeve my name is
Alice leave look at this
it's this is so cute is really I
absolutely love it
Blagh looking forward to setting these
up and I would give you guys an update
later I'm so excited to show you my blog
office you know give you a little
preview there's nothing in it yet but
some things will be won't do that again
it's all set up this is such a great
monitor like I'm super in love with it
what's great about this monitor is it's
us PC and it's Thunderbolt so I can just
plug this directly in to my laptop and
here we are we're ready to edit so let's
open up some final cut this looks really
great
I love having this much screen real
estate like I've got look at this
timeline look at this time would you
look and then I can just like Oh I'm
lounging now if anybody really saw like
what like this is what you're seeing it
this is what I'm usually like I'm so
excited to edit on this I haven't got a
chance to set up my gaming area yet
that's gonna be coming pretty soon so I
look forward to showing you guys where
that new monitor is gonna go there's a
lot of stuff happening right now here's
a sneak peek just give them a real quick
like just look okay you're done you're
done you're done you're done you're done
you're done so excited about redoing my
office I can't wait to show you guys
that'll be coming very soon I know I
basically have this really terrible
problem of once I get something
absolutely perfect just how I like it I
like to destroy it and completely start
over which is what I did with this place
so look for all those fun things coming
soon if you guys have any suggestions
for things that you'd like to see me
make videos about leave those in the
comments below I'll see you guys in the
next video
[Music]